jetpacks also raketen rucksäcke sind
wohl richtige sehnsucht objekte der
menschen forschungsteams weltweit haben
unverdrossen daran getüftelt diesen
traum für jedermann zur wirklichkeit
werden zu lassen
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und die spannende frage ist
ist das überhaupt realistisch oder
wurden alle projekte auf eis gelegt die
überraschende antwort jetzt bei pixum
science fiction herzlich willkommen das
ist wirklich unglaublich schon mehr als
100 jahre sind forschungsteams weltweit
dabei jetpacks zu entwickeln schon 1919
hatte sich ein russischer ingenieur zur
aufgabe gemacht ein tragbares fluggerät
herzustellen doch das projekt war nicht
wirklich von erfolg gekrönt später
zeigte dann das militär großes interesse
und vor allem wernher von braun
verfolgte diese idee weiter her hatte
zunächst für die nazis geforscht und die
waffen v1 und v2 entwickelt und danach
für die usa
die saturn 5 mondrakete rund 30 jahre
nach den ersten anfängen also in den
60er jahren gab es dann die ersten
prototypen die auch was drauf hatten 13
sekunden lang konnte das 57 kilogramm
schwere jetpack der den eishockeyspieler
harrell gremme fliegen lassen ohne seil
und sicherung der erste mensch überhaupt
dem das gelungen war
doch der jetpack verbrauchte dabei ganze
40 liter treibstoff pro minute trotzdem
träumt weiter vom mofa für die lüfte das
verkehrsmittel der zukunft an den job
gekommen war herr ingram durch den
erfinder thomas nur er war seit vielen
jahren schon dabei einen raketenrucksack
zu entwickeln er selbst war schon ein
paar sekunden zumindest abgehoben doch
dann passiert denn der tragische unfall
etwa beim zwanzigsten test schwebt der
drei meter über den boden und wurde
übermütig erstreckte deren arm raus und
begab sich in die horizontale da
passierte es das nylon seil das ihn
abgesichert hatte verfängt sich in den
meisten diesen und schmolz er fällt zu
boden bricht sich die kniescheibe und
wird seitdem nicht mehr fliegen können
sein ersatz der eishockey-spieler herren
gramm 1961 durch dieser dann auf dem
flughafen der niagara falls 20 meter
weit und die zeitung feiern das als den
durchbruch zitat der traum vom fliegen
mit den vögeln ist wahr geworden so eine
schlagzeile dennoch die nachteile
überwiegen zudem übermäßig hohen
treibstoffverbrauch kamen
dass das ganze super unpraktisch
anzuziehen war
dafür braucht es eine ganze mannschaft
an helfern doch dann noch 184 gab es
einen großen erfolg da wurden die
olympischen spiele in allen mit bild und
einem jetpack eröffnet
doch auch hier dasselbe problem der
treibstoffverbrauch man einfach viel zu
groß vor allem war dieser in dieser zeit
auch noch immer teurer geworden neue
chancen einen jet pack zu entwickeln
erhoffte man sich dann mit dem aufstieg
des silicon valleys so hatten nicht nur
kleinere startups sondern auch große
it-konzerne ein auge auf die entwicklung
von jet packs geworfen unter anderem
auch das forschungslabor von google doch
relativ schnell stellte sich dann heraus
dass weitere forschungsarbeit wohl
keinen sinn machen würde und die pläne
wurden auf eis gelegt und
erstaunlicherweise waren es übrigens
nicht die möglichen risiken die zu
dieser entscheidung führten sondern wohl
mal wieder dass treibstoff problem die
hohe lautstärke und das teure auftanken
das jedenfalls berichten insider eine
umweltschonende möglichkeit sah da sei
damit ausgeschlossen gewesen die
entwicklung einer sicheren technologie
dagegen sei theoretisch möglich gewesen
komplett gestorben ist die idee der jet
packs dennoch nicht das startup jetpack
aviation hat tatsächlich eine erste
version herausgebracht hat so heißt es
auf der webseite des unternehmens
pendeln durch die luft während andere im
verkehr fest stecken schnelle
medizinische notfallversorgung will jede
sekunde leben retten kann oder spazieren
sie einfach an einem sonntagnachmittag
durch den park und schweben hoch wie ein
adler
das ziel ist jetzt das ding
massentauglich zu machen sagt so ist
jedoch noch viel forschung und
entwicklung notwendig und genau dafür
läuft gerade eine crowd funding kampagne
ja hier geht es weiter mit
dafür draufklicken fliegen wir bald mit
überschall
und wenn er kein video mehr zu diesen
und allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann folgt mir auf whatsapp nur da
bekommt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
das neueste video ganz unabhängig von
der abo box hier auf youtube die er bei
dem ein oder andere nicht so ganz
perfekt funktioniert trotzdem natürlich
ein abo gerne da lassen und natürlich
nicht dem
die glocke vergessen bis dann bleibt
dran